[Music]
good morning guys we are in Disneyland
or technically California Adventure
today yeah we got some free tickets and
I was like oh my gosh we gotta come and
then cases here and then my brother
Adrian is here yeah use the youngest of
the three from my mom's side so we're
like hey dude we got an extra ticket
join us so this is your first time
coming since you're like eight right and
now you're a freshman in high school
yeah it's great something about that I
know it's different I remember some
things but you know you never been to
California huh he never really
California Adventure so excited is from
the day here I actually have to leave in
the middle of the day because I'm going
to am I'm not concert and if you know
anything about me you know that I am
obsessed with my not in the Cure and
I've got to see the cure few years ago
and I get to go see my now so the boys
are gonna stay once I leave I'm really
scared cuz we're gonna
credit coach right now I know you're too
terrified I am terrified she is not a
really good man feel your heartbeat oh
my gosh that thing is pounding yeah oh
my goodness you're gonna be fine dude
don't worry you're gonna love it
afterwards side note it's like a
thousand degrees I'm burning up my
cheeks are so red my makeup is melting
oh let's go get on in credit go straight
this way
[Music]
you are about to ride whatever instead
of coaster is it is to ride that you've
been waiting to ride for a long time
right yeah also scared opponents why you
scared to go it's a really cool trick
that is well and credit coaster you
think it's pretty incredible yeah it's
me incredibly fast incredibly incredibly
fun incredibly fun are you incredibly
nervous yes alright so how was the in
credit coaster awesome enjoyed it yeah I
like I like the loop too
yeah whoo what's your favorite part on
it probably the big drop
yeah if you had to tell yourself one
thing or something I have some advice to
you before you got on the ride I know
what would you tell yourself you can
enjoy it
and the English rate is gonna make me a
roller coaster oh yeah yeah you came out
of the roller coaster feels like home I
was real secret now like yeah I
converted her nose 11 to
[Music]
[Music]
we better bring this right in my life in
a minute
[Music]
at least we did pretty good we got
through we got on three rides since
we've been here the one place yeah but
they're flying with sure keep on eating
planet rollercoaster Sorna
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now this is a milk
[Applause]
are you tired I'm really tired are you
tired Isaac no a little bit
I'm hoot I'm glad you're 11 years old
you're like the brother tail-end of
taking you to Disneyland but then I was
thinking what if you have a little
brother or a little sister in the future
we're gonna be back to Disneyland many
more times if that happens I'm dreading
it it's so tiring you're falling this
top part is gonna fall any second you
got a landslide happening so what you're
buying just now
let me see that Lucky Penny
I used to believe in lucky pennies too
until I picked up a Lucky Penny at night
oh I may have good luck forever
might work well has it work I'm not a
temp arts good luck on you the moment
you touch it
[Music]
me too I'm always hopeful that like a
good luck how many lucky pennies have
you picked up in your lifetime that has
anything good happened to your life
recently coming to Disneyland huh even
though you're feeling kind of under the
weather this is like your day guys
Disney on one end and yanma not exactly
I know I'm gonna come home with no
makeup on I'm ready like free baby
yeah pregame I'm already kinda cranky
look too fast but found like only a
little bit look it's really strong they
gave you that sampler I was a holy crap
this is way more tequila than anything
else in there and strong it's way funner
to say uber than grabbing a lift
I need a lift but uber everywhere huh I
think so these young kids these days and
their rap songs you know
[Music]
oh so you know do you like mine ah you
know my Spanish rock band from the 80s
and 90s or 90s
[Music]
[Music]
that was me and my dad at the Paul
McCartney concert we went to back in
like 2006 or something like that like we
knew all the old Beatles stuff and like
the wing stuff and like all the you know
it's 80 stuff but then like once it got
to like the early 2000s and like his
newer albums were like what is this
back to the Holman odd thing it was it's
really cool that you're going out
tonight with Gio and Stacey and Bo's
because I feel like you see them at your
sisters and earlier today you're talking
about that story about how you would
listen to my now with your sisters and
like you would tell me like how like
they would reinterpret all your all the
lyrics and stuff back then for you and
my for you to really had a moment of
manal with your sisters back in the day
so for you to go today with your new
sisters I think that's really dope very
full circle
then with the poaching diabetes in a
bowl right there have you ever seen one
[Music]
I have fun be safe and call me when you
get there and bear there and back she
won't she's off on her own
we're on our own to a boys night out the
Disneyland cool Halloween stuff I've
never been to Disneyland during
Halloween all right so before TIFF left
you were doing a little pregame efort it
for her a little Minaj concert that's
happening and I was cranking with her
she didn't finish her drink so I was the
one that chugged the rest of her drink
before we parted ways and then
Disneyland of why you're a little tipsy
is freaking fun we like to do that here
you like baby daddy can you tell the
difference no good that's the answer I
was looking for whoo
how long we've been waiting for this
there's only so many hours you could
spend standing in one line sometimes
Disney is complete torture world's for
those time-consuming plates while doing
nothing absolutely either way yeah I do
[Music]
both and I are pretty with Casey Isaac
and Adrian are still it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]